in this video you're going to learn how
to graph absolute value
functions with transformations so we're
going to be working with this form of
the
equation of the absolute value function
and we're going to talk about how to
shift the graph how to stretch the graph
how to reflect the graph
but first we want to talk about what is
the basic shape of an absolute value
a function graph and so what we're going
to do is we're going to look at the
parent function which is this guy right
here
y equals absolute value of x we're going
to plug in some negative values
0 and some positive values in a table
now remember when you put in negative 3
here the absolute value
always makes that quantity positive so
if it's negative it's going to be
positive
if it's 0 it's going to be 0 and if it's
positive
it's going to stay positive so whatever
you put in here you do that operation
absolute value it's going to be positive
now if we graph these points
what you're going to see here is that
we're going to get a
v-shape graph so it's going to have a
real sharp corner
unlike a parabola which has that u shape
to it
and when you graph these points there's
your
parent function now notice this point
here at the origin 0
0 see where the graph bends or in this
case it's a real sharp corner there
that's your vertex
okay and we're going to be paying a
close attention to that vertex point
because that's going to be
h and k in this more generalized way of
writing the function
so let's go to another example here
number one y equals
two times the absolute value of x minus
one plus three
now the way that i like to do these uh
graphs here is i like to think of the
shift first so i think of okay this one
here means that i'm going to shift to
the right one
and the plus 3 is up 3. now you're
probably saying mario isn't this a minus
1
shouldn't that be left one what you want
to do is the number that's grouped with
the x here that's going to shift the
graph in the x direction
but it's going to have the opposite
effect so minus 1 means we're actually
going to go
positive 1 if this was plus 1 we would
go negative 1.
okay so remember the one here is
opposite this one here the k value
it's going to be the same as the sign
what i mean by that is positive 3
we're gonna go up three minus three
we're gonna go down three
so this is gonna be right one up three
that's gonna be our vertex right there
that's where that graph has that
uh change in direction there and you've
got two options now one option which i
really like
is to look at this number in front of
the absolute value that's this a value
here this is what
stretches the graph or compresses the
graph or reflects the graph
now if it's greater than one it's going
to be a stretch it's kind of like we're
pulling on this graph in the vertical
direction we're stretching it which is
actually going to make the graph
narrower if this a value is in between 0
and 1 like a half or a third
it's going to be what we call a vertical
shrink you're going to be compressing it
towards the x-axis which is actually
going to make it wider
and then if it's negative the negative
is going to reflect it
so it's going to be opening down like
that okay so in this case you can see
it's
2 you can think of 2 as like 2 over 1
and 2 over 1 is going to be like our
slopes we're going to go rise
2 run 1 rise 2 and i'm going to go the
opposite direction because notice this
is symmetric
this parabola about that vertex so you
can see it's a little bit narrower
because the a was stretching it okay
vertical stretch and you can see that
it's shifting at right one and up three
now another way to do this one
is to make a table and a lot of students
like this method here
and what you would do is you would place
your vertex in the
middle here so let's go ahead and do
that so our vertex we said was at 1
3 and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to pick some points on either side
so for example
2 and 0 3 and negative 1
because it's going to be the same on
both sides so for example if i was to
put 2
okay in for x 2 minus 1 is 1. the
absolute value of 1 is 1
times 2 is 2 plus 3 is 5.
this will also be 5. if we put in 3 for
x 3 minus 1 is
2 the absolute value of 2 is 2 times 2
is 4
plus 3 is 7. this will also be the 7
because it's the same on both sides
then you can just plot from the origin
but the method that i'm showing you is
to think of this a
value as the slope like rise over run
and that's just a quick way to do it
once you find that point you reflect it
over that
line of symmetry the line that divides
the
absolute value graph in half let's look
at one more example
number two here we've got y equals
negative one half
times the absolute value of x plus three
minus two
so what do you think the three and the
negative two do to the graph
well if you said left three you're right
because remember this is the opposite so
negative three
this one has the same effect negative
two so we're gonna go left three
down two so let's get the green marker
out here
left three down two that's our vertex
i'll just label it v
and the negative one half what do you
think the negative one half is going to
do to the graph
well if you said that it's going to
reflect it because it's negative you're
right
and the one half is going to compress it
making that graph like wider
but what i like to do is i like to think
of this as like the slope
so from the vertex here i'm going to go
down 1 because negative one
and then right two and i could also go
negative one and left
two because it's the same on both sides
so you can see it's wider okay
because of the one-half and it's opening
down because
the a value is negative now if you don't
like that method go ahead and make a
table a lot of teachers
show it this way a lot of students like
this method and go ahead and put that
vertex in the middle
so for example here plus 3 would be
negative 3 negative 2
and you want to pick points on either
side so like negative 4 and negative 2
negative 5 and negative 1 and then you
can plot these and you're going to get
some additional points
on either side of the vertex to help you
get a good graph now the only thing that
i haven't talked about yet
is the domain and the range now the
domain is whatever the
x values can be right so in this case
because the graph is going to the left
and the right
forever and ever we would say the domain
for this one is
all real numbers and actually for all
three of these the domain is all reals
now if we're talking about the range
we're talking about what can the y
values be
right so if we're looking at this last
one we did the y values can only be at
this point or
lower so you see how that y value is at
negative 2 or below
so here for the range we would say y
is less than or equal to negative 2. so
it can equal negative 2
or below whereas say for example this
one it would be y
is equal to 3 or greater
so if you want to see more examples
about working with transformations like
these shifts and these stretches not
just with absolute value functions but
with
quadratic functions cubic functions
greatest integer functions all different
types of functions
to get a feel of how to work with these
follow me to that video right there
and we'll dive into some more examples